that was in midian at minneapolis from
his home studio in south florida
cole's proud papa was watching along and
this
was the reaction the tiger fist pump
and now joining us for the magic of
television officially now and forever
he is only to be called cole's daddy
yeah congratulations happily thanks guys
take us through it yeah take us through
your feeling right now
you know you it's a weird feeling and
you're riding
the the roller coaster with them you
know you're watching the game and you're
seeing
you know you should do this you should
do that and things aren't
you know necessarily going the way you
want you can see that the confidence
wasn't you know where you'd like to see
it and that's to be expected
uh but he stayed patient and he you know
the victory he hit also was right
before that one on a play from james
ennis on the kickout
he hit a three from you know that side
of the floor uh the possession prior and
then to be able to get that one that
that
play happens because he's probably not
thinking and you know when sometimes
when you're struggling
you're thinking a little too much and
that was just reactionary so it was uh
it was awesome to see man the team
needed it and then just to see the
reaction from the guys
uh in a game where they just really did
not look good for three quarters
and uh to be able to come by come back
and get that win
and i'm just so happy for him and them